lo que pasa es que en el gobierno
anterior de Jair bolsonaro pues no era
tan cercano a la casa blanca la casa
blanca de Joe biden es muy diciente El
recibimiento que tuvo sin embargo nula
da Silva que pues se duró casi dos horas
en reunión
privada con Joe biden y el tema
principal fue es el tema principal fue
el medio ambiente en el cambio climático
todavía no hay un anuncio concreto sobre
si Estados Unidos se une al fondo pero
lo que está tratando de hacer Lula en
cuanto a su relación con El Ejecutivo y
también en sus reuniones en el congreso
es tratar de activar esa ayuda esa ayuda
que yo vaya prometió recordemos 20 mil
millones de dólares de ayuda a la
conversación a la a la a proteger la
mayoría y a Pues el luchar contra la
deforestación sin embargo esos veinte
mil millones de dólares no han sido
todavía Pues de usados ni han sido
todavía repar a las diferentes agencias
internacionales para la ayuda en este
fin entonces precisamente este punto y
este tema es el que trata de activar
aquí en Washington Cristóbal en cuanto a
la Guerra de Ucrania que dijo allí que
dijeron allí los presidentes Lula por lo
menos propone la creación de este grupo
de países para fomentar el diálogo entre
las partes y aprovecho también por para
preguntarle por el tema de China qué más
dijeran
claro es un tema bastante central el de
Ucrania también el de china en cuanto en
cuanto Ucrania concretamente Pues el ula
repitió varias veces que era importante
era trascendental parar inmediatamente
las acciones bélicas para poder sentarse
a negociar llegar a un acuerdo pero que
lo primero era eso de tener todo el tema
de las acciones bélicas y esto de alguna
manera es un mensaje a muchas países de
Europa que están en este momento pues
prometiendo insinuando ya dar no
solamente tanques de guerra sino aviones
en cuanto a China concretamente pues es
una de las preocupaciones que muchos
congresistas tienen tanto demócratas
como republicanos y es la creciente
influencia de china en Brasil en cuanto
al control minero sobre todo que pues
esos recursos mineros se usan mucho en
temas de
electrodomésticos y aparatos
electrónicos que le termina dando mucho
poder a China y que cuestionan entonces
esa relación que Brasil sigue sigue
permitiendo que china desarrolle
económicamente en el Continente sur y
concretamente en Brasil